[Music]
i keep asking questions of what's going
on and nobody's telling me anything
nobody's telling any telling anything
and one of the parents were saying that
there's kids possibly held
at the funeral home we can't get
anything we can't get any uh anything as
little as they're okay they're not okay
or we're still waiting or you know
no information has been released to any
of the parents here
[Music]
what happened in uvalde
is a horrific tragedy
that cannot be tolerated in the state of
texas and there is swift action being
taken by
local law enforcement as well as the
texas department of public safety the
shooter was salvador romas
an 18 year old male who resided in
uvalde
what are we doing
they've been more mass shootings than
days in the year
our kids are living in fear
every single time they set foot in the
classroom because they think they're
going to be next
what are we doing
why do you spend all this time running
for the united states senate
why do you go through all the hassle
of getting this job
of putting yourself in a position of
authority
if your answer
is that as this slaughter increases as
our kids run for their lives we do
nothing
what are we doing
why are you here
if not
to solve
a problem as existential as this
this isn't inevitable
these kids weren't unlucky
this only happens in this country
and nowhere else
nowhere else do little kids go to school
thinking that they might be shot that
day
[Music]
[Music]
as a nation we have to ask when in god's
name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
when in god's name
we do we all know in our gut needs to be
done
[Music]
you